Sometimes these movements have to be driven by people who are true believers,
because what happens is they,
they push things all the way over and then it comes back.
Americans are not an extreme people. We are not extreme.
Americans are not socialist. Americans are not super right wing.
Americans want a better life for their kids for the most part and are too busy
with, with, with their everyday thing.
I got to take my kid to baseball and I want to be able to afford afterschool
activities for my kids. That's what they really care about.
I want a little extra cash.
I'm Dave Rubin,
and this is the Rubin report as always guys click that subscribe button and that
little notification bell.
So you have a small chance at least of seeing our videos and joining me today as
a comedian and actor and co-host of the fire and the kid podcast.
Brian Callen. Welcome to the Rubin report. Thank you, sir. Look at fan big fan.
Love it. Big fan. Finally made it you're in the internet.
Now this is like the center of the [inaudible]. Yes
, this right here. Everything that we say here stays here. No one will get in
any trouble here. Exactly fine.
As long as you, uh, as long as you don't express yourself freely, thoughtfully,
and with reason.
That seems like a good place to start. Yeah. Comedy in an age of cancellation,
how are you feeling these days?
I think that it feels as though this is the last
bastion for satire, honest expression, original self-expression,
you know, I've had comments comment and say, well,
I've got the show with a certain network and I'm afraid that what I said, uh,
I expressed a point of view that was more complicated than some black or white,
no pun intended. Yeah. You know, you're going forward and should I,
should I do this? You,
you have comics now wondering if they should edit themselves in podcasts.
And my answer is if that is, what, if you are,
um, worried about that because you're working for that network,
then you shouldn't work for that network. Then you're no longer a comic.
Then you're no longer in the business of original self-expression
thoughts.
And art has always been there to disturb to shake things
up. Let's take will. And grace, as an example,
I auditioned for that show maybe five times.
I can't remember if it was for Jack. It was for Eric. It was for both.
And I knew it was going to be a hit, but it was so groundbreaking.
It was so astonishing.
It was the first time that gay people were kind of highlighted as this,
um, as people with senses of humor who wanted the same thing,
that straight people. I remember that being a radical new, uh,
idea. And it, you know, back then, you know,
we always talk about how you can get canceled for certain words, you say, well,
in the, um, well,
let's say all to all of American history up through probably nineties.
If you were found out to be gay in a, in the workplace, well,
if you didn't get fired, you weren't going to get promoted.
It was a major liability and physically dangerous.
So along comes will and grace and a
network took a risk. So in that sense, you know, you can,
you can point to examples where it's very important to continue to speak your
mind. And it's very important when the pendulum swings too far, right,
or too far left or too far in any direction as an artist, you got to push back,
you got to kind of go, you gotta make fun of it. And that's the one,
the through all this insanity. And there are a lot of bad ideas out there.
And there are a lot of sort of like, um, there's, we're very polarized.
There's no room for nuances, you know, as I'm sure you've picked up on, but, um,
I do think Americans have this really great safety valve, this switch,
which is humor. We tend to make fun of ourselves. We tend to make fun of,
of cancel culture already. We tend to make fun of, of all of these things. Uh,
w th th there's Trump has always being made fun of. And so is the other side.
So I think at least we are going to always,
w we'll we'll always have that thing. Even kids now,
my friend's son who is 16, my, my, his, my buddy said,
look at that, look at that butterfly, wonder what he's gonna land on next.
And his friend said, dad, how are you assuming that's a, Hey, I mean,
how do you know? And already kids are making fun of this stuff.
So I think that's very healthy.
But doesn't,
this seem a little unique in that there's like a runaway train aspect to her
right now, where used to be kind of like, Oh,
one person randomly said one thing and they get taken out where now it just
feels like the whole track got destroyed. The train is going off,
and everyone's kind of going with it at the same time.
We were, if this was 1968,
we'd be saying the same thing and we'd be even more panicked. You know? Um,
I think right now we're dealing with a confluence of events.
You're dealing with, you know, the George Floyd,
the terrible murder of George Florida.
You're dealing with COVID-19 where nobody has jobs and nobody has anywhere to go
to. Uh,
and you're dealing with all these uncertainties and you're dealing with this
incredibly polarizing figure named Donald Trump so that all of
that stuff I think is a perfect storm. So it's when you're in it,
it's hard to see a way out of it. And it's hard to see sense.
I do think again, there are a lot of bad ideas out there, and I do think that,
um, but again, if I'm a moderate person, I just am,
I'm naturally moderate, medium, uh.
Your show. We were trying to figure out what we might differ on politically.
We couldn't come up with that.
No, I think you're a very reasonable, I've listened to you many times and I,
and I've listened to your guests and your, I, you know,
truth is you are a reasonable fair-minded person.
Don't tell that to the New York times. Well, you know, again, I think,
and, and then I, I find myself saying, you know, um,
sometimes these movements have to be driven by people who are true believers,
because what happens is they, they pushed things all the way over,
and then it comes back. Americans are not an extreme people. We are not extreme.
Americans are not socialist. Americans are not super right wing.
Americans want a better life for their kids for the most part,
and are too busy with, with, with their every day thing.
I gotta take my kid to baseball and I want to be able to afford afterschool
activities for my kids. That's what they really care about.
I want a little extra cash. I mean, if you really come down to it,
and I think that they, the silent majority,
the most they ever really do is write letters. Please. We tweet now, come on,
you know, stuff like that. But, but, but, you know, come election time.
A lot of times, if, if, if they feel like their bottom line is being affected,
I E the way their children are being raised educated and, uh,
and,
and whether or not they have a little extra cash in their pocket that that'll
get them to the polls. Otherwise, eh, I got enough for this,
and I got enough for that. Yeah.
I want to stick with the comedy thing for a little bit,
because you mentioned how,
if you're a comic and you're working at a network that's making you sense or
making you question yourself, then you're working at the wrong place. Yes.
Isn't it odd though, that for all of us that are now in the podcast, YouTube,
whatever you want to call this thing that now we're watching ourselves do it to
ourselves. We're, we're our own bosses.
I'm not saying you're doing it and I'm not doing it,
but we know a lot of people now that are getting in trouble because of what's
being said on podcasts. And we know that, you know,
media matters watches every word that somebody is going to say so that if,
you know, anybody says one thing, the wrong way that you're taking them out,
even though these guys own their stuff.
Yeah. Um, but trouble, when you say getting in trouble, the truth is that,
um,
they're not the truth is I look at getting in trouble as not being able to earn
a living. Uh, you know, um,
corporations are incredibly in many ways spineless,
and we'll get into that in a second. And what I mean by that, but, but, um,
I think that you're still a little bit, look,
I I'm on stage all the time I was in Arizona. I was in Texas. Um,
anywhere I go, when I,
when I say things that seem reasonable when I criticize
the sort of, even whether it's conservatives or liberals and I,
I criticize both. People love it.
People clap, people laugh because.
Uh, typically I think I always find that if I'm feeling this way,
so as most of the country, yeah, because most people are just reasonable.
They're not indoctrinated into an ideology if you like.
Okay. For more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.